When the Conjunction happened,
it wasn't just the elves.
Humans, dwarfs…
Spheres of beasts collided too.
Then, 300 years ago,
mages weaponized men,
made them fast,
strong,
brutal enough to kill the beasts.
The witchers
saved humanity from extinction.
This is your home?
How many did you say there were?
There were 20.
Now?
Maybe less.
A witcher is a trained killer.
Professional monster hunter.
Witchers have that
heightened sense of things.
They came in as very young,
and they're transformed
to get unhuman power.
Trained to such an extreme
that they are no longer
really human.
To fight against
beasts and monsters.
We thought you got lost. Or killed.
Not yet. Sorry.
Brother!
Kaer Morhen is the keep
of the witchers,
the School of the Wolf.
The witchers descend there
every winter
to feel rooted to a family.
The only family
that they really know.
He's home!
Who the hell are you?
He takes Ciri there to protect her.
It is the safest place he knows.
Stay here.
I brought her here so she'd be safe.
It's easier for me to protect her
within these walls.
It's hard to do when I don't know
who I'm protecting her from.
Vesemir, he is the leader
of the witchers,
and Ciri has a lot of respect for him.
You're impressing
all of us out there.
There's a brotherhood there.
They're not bound by blood.
They're bound together
by the sacrifices they've made.
Neither you nor I
can just forget who we are.
It's one of those wonderful things
where you have
the big, complex worlds,
and in that,
you get to tell really humble,
really simple human stories.
-Who's ready?
-Eskel!
It's about family
and exploring what family means,
which is, I think,
what the witchers represent.
Do what you do best.
Stay and fight.